[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and we just got some
massive news about the seven deadly sins
after years of waiting after a whole
bunch of fake news and rumors after
Netflix falsely claimed to have seven
deadly sins season two when it only had
a four episode TV special called signs
of a holy war which created a huge
confusion we finally have official
confirmation that the seven that he sent
season two the real season 2 will be
coming in January of 2018 we also some
crazy news about a 70 cent movie that
will be coming out next summer so be
sure to stick around until the very end
of the videos to make sure that you have
all the news all the information that we
have to share for you and big thanks to
cootie gohan from our discord server for
informing me and giving me a heads up
about this big news here at anime opra
we're going to keep you posted for all
the latest news about $0.70 season 2 and
a whole bunch of other animes so if
you're new to the channel be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
but yes the breaking news here is that
at a recent
non-eternal taizai FPS event in tokyo it
was confirmed that 7 Delhi since season
2 is coming in January of 2018 and
season 2 is going to be called revival
of the commandments this is really
exciting news for all seven of these
tens fans because while we've been
getting some news lately about video
games coming out some of the descents
video games a ps4 game we've all been
waiting for this big season 2 news and
it's finally here especially after all
the fake news we've been getting this is
a really really good development and if
you're worried that this is also fake
news don't worry we check the official
Japanese website for the sound of these
since the news is there and it's also
been carried by crunchyroll and the
anime news network a short teaser or PV
has been released for the second season
however it mostly features old footage
footage from the signs of a holy war TV
special only at the end at the very end
we get a glimpse of the Ten Commandment
of course if you're caught up to the
anime you know that at the end of the
signs of the holy war TV special
hendrickson man
to open the coffin of eternal darkness
meaning that he is not going to
resurrect the notorious demon clan if
you're a manga reader you know exactly
who the 10 commandments are however if
you've only seen the anime in again the
signs of a holy war TV special we did
get the information that the Ten
Commandments are the most elite and most
powerful warriors of the demon king
along with the PV a short character
video has also been released and this
video features the new characters that
are going to be appearing in season 2
the images of the new characters appear
to be just manga drawings that have been
colored in however they still look
pretty cool and we get our first glimpse
and eScan or the final seven deadly sin
as well as a bunch of the commandments
oh yeah really cool stuff and if you
want to check out the full TV or teaser
and the full character video I will
leave a link below to the Anime News
network's story on this because they
feature both videos on their website so
go and check it out
the main Japanese voice cast is
returning which is great news for me
because you guys know that I only watch
the sub and of course we're going to
have new voice actors voicing the new
characters including tomokazu sugita and
Eska nor can I get some Eskin or hype
down in the comments please so yeah this
is amazing news for seven deadly sins
fans after all these years and all these
rumors and fake news we are finally
getting confirmation that season 2 is a
go January 2018 and I really hope that
this is good news for people waiting for
news about other anime as well like code
geass season 3 which we've been waiting
for a long time I have to say I
personally have been frustrated by the
lack of news for Code Geass however the
fact that now after all this merchandise
selling for some does extends they are
getting a second season and we know that
Code Geass is selling a lot of
merchandise as well I hope that we can
look forward to that news code geass
season 3 release date sometime soon and
of course we got some great news a
recently about attack on Titan season 3
overlord season 2 food Wars season 3 so
I think it's going to be a good year for
anime for sequels those long-awaited
seasons so yeah definitely a lot of hype
guys very excited let me know if you're
excited
down below another exciting piece of
news is that a seven deadly sins anime
movie will be coming out
time next summer now we're not sure if
this movie is going to be a retelling of
the story if it's going to be a Side
Story or something completely different
however I can't wait to find out it
looks very interesting and of course
here at anime out for we're going to
keep you posted on all the latest news
about $0.70 season 2 attack on titan
season 3 code geass season 3 and a whole
bunch of other anime news so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
and if you want to join our discord
server where we discuss anime news and
theories on a daily basis link is in the
description it's a free app and it's a
great time be sure to check it out as
always thank you so much for watching
seventh of these sin season 2 hype and
until next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]